Are infrared or near infrared sodas good for cancer?
Um, yes, yes they are.
Well, let's take a step back.
So the infrared and near infrared sodas.
Really are just sources of heat.
So, um, a true infrared unit will not show any color as it's below the red spectra.
So, honestly, a true infrared unit that's, you know, that's producing infrared is about it that like our infrared hyperthermia unit is only like six inches by five inches.
And those things are like five grain, okay.
So, uh, you think that you're getting true infrared.
I don't care what their brochure says from the panel that heats up.
No, you are not.
Plus true infrared heats deep in the tissue.
It doesn't really have surface heat.
So a true infrared or an infrared solder near infrared sauna.
Right.
Honestly, you're not really getting any of the benefits, no matter what the company says from infrared radiation.
That's just out there.
So just cross at them.
So let's just say sawdust or sawdust good for cancer.
The answer is yes.
And the reason is is because you're sweating and when you're sweating, you're helping detoxify through your skin.
And you're taking pressure off your liver and your kidneys.
That's why it's good.
But infrared, you have to get a hyperthermia unit.
It has to be skin to skin contact.
It has to be about six inches away from your skin.
And it's only going to treat a very small area at one time.